candidates and Asians ladies and
gentlemen thank you for your patience
I'm now moving to the first declaration
of this election as a declaration
resolve poll for election of a member of
parliament for Coventry self on Thursday
length of June 2017 I
Martin Reeves being the acting returning
officer at the above election do hereby
give notice by the number of votes
recorded for each candidate at the said
elections is as follows Challinor Amy
green party 604 Cunningham James Dolan
the Labour Party candidate 25,000 874
Finlay
Sandra independent 224 judge Greg Paul
Liberal Democrat 1343 low Michelle Jane
Maria the Conservative Party candidate
17,000 927 Rogers Ian Arthur UK
Independence Party you Kip 1037 the
total number of ballot papers rejected
was 114 the turnout for this
constituency was 66 0.65% and I do
hereby declare that James Dolan
Cunningham is duly elected
[Applause]
first of all I'd like to thank the
people of Coventry for reelecting people
with seven thing we think it is know
I've been coming here for many many
years
secondly what a way to do his thing
certainly my AGG of oil local party
chair Lindsey Harvard my campaign tin
item Dave Priya
shark and Jason Bonnie can you never
gets mentioned and of course as many
others who health we had hundreds of
people when we started out came to help
us and they've maintained that help all
the way through the election I think
they've been so extending results
tonight that if we went back four or
five weeks ago we certainly never
thought we would be where we are today
not only in terms of cognitive south how
about parts of the country and it shows
that you can never take the British
people for granted and I think it also
demonstrates that the British people
have had enough of austerity now said
that yours retains no use of Commons and
of course this will bring an end to
austerity the results tonight should we
the NSA agent is not they present
Conservative government afflict many
more cuts because it'll help was seller
defend the National Health Service the
Education Service and numerous other
services they've been under constant
attack over the last six or seven years
so with that I'm not going to bore you
anymore
but once again I want to thank everybody
they helped me and a particular and have
not mentioned that my way thank